a legend around this chalk is that it's
impossible to write a false theorem
I assume the special ingredients where's
angel tears mathematicians from all the
top schools very frequently is it it's a
cult favorite as soon as I used it I was
a convert the chalk is one of the
best-kept secrets in the math world it's
the rolls-royce of chalk
[Music]
hagoromo is a brand of Japanese chalk
the way it flows on a board is a bit
hard to describe in words it's really
hard to get you can only get it from
Japan you need a Japanese person to
bring it back for you I discovered it
when I went to visit the University of
Tokyo and one of the professor's there
said to me you know we have better chalk
than you do in the States and I said oh
go on chalk his chalk and so I tried it
out and I was surprised to find that he
was right I tried it I thought was
phenomenal it's the densest it erases
the cleanest that leaves the nicest line
if you use bad chalk often you're
depressed really hard for anyone to see
what you're writing
so using hagoromo on a good board it
doesn't really feel like you're working
hard to write when I'm teaching I get a
feeling of energy confidence and the
chalk absolutely helps slowly the math
world has become aware of this and it
became a bit of a fad in some circles
who knows like maybe four years ago the
word came out that the company was going
out of business
I sort of jokingly referred to it as a
chalk apocalypse so I immediately
started hoarding up as much as I could I
order three boxes of hagoromo and kept
in my office and used it very sparingly
I should have bought more but I have
friends that bought boxes and boxes and
boxes of the stuff they might very well
be set for the rest of their career
without like 1506 that's a lot of days
for sticks a day I think I'm gonna make
it I have probably a ten year supplies
still at home I calculated how many
boxes what I needed to last for 10 or 15
years I didn't want to become a talk to
you later but I did like the idea that I
could be the first stick is free chalk
dealer on the block in my department I
was probably selling it regularly to
maybe eight to ten colleagues I would
reach into my cupboard in my office and
pull out another box and we do the deal
in my office and we all had a chalk fix
and we still do the original hygroma
chalk is slowly disappearing a few years
ago a Korean company bought their
formulas and did the best job of
faithfully reproducing and agree it was
mixed emotions I was happy to know that
it would still be made but I was a
little disappointed that I was less
clever than I thought I was
in many ways mathematics is like
craftsmanship in some ways it's like
artistry in some ways it's like science
but there's a real toy craft side to
giving a beautiful lecture on a
blackboard mathematicians admire this at
each other and like teams the best tools
for it there's incredible value to this
but the value isn't using it up not
hoarding it
[Music]
you
[Music]